le temps des mécènes comme l'était
howard use a bien disparu dans le monde
du cinéma mais il y a un point commun
entre ce milliardaire mort dans le
mystère est un jeune comédien français
dont la carrière en quelques mois s'est
développé une façon fulgurante
je parlais de gérard depardieu je pense
que le point commun de leur caractère et
cette forme de violence interne avec
laquelle depardieu heurter bouscule
certains thèmes de notre société
vedette de la dernière femme où le héros
écrase et par les difficultés du couple
se mutile avec un couteau électrique
voici gérard depardieu 26 ans numéro un
du peloton des acteurs les plus demandés
en 24 mois et 7 films il est passée de
l'obscurité au salaire à six chiffres
hiver au printemps dans sa maison de
banlieue ou dans les rues de saint
germain des prés il porte les mêmes
bottes les mêmes blouson la richesse et
la célébrité n'ont pas changé son
apparence
je ne vais pas dit un jour tiens je
viens de signer un très bon contrat
j'aime faire à des noms cadeau non je
vais manger sainement que je dors
tranquille
j'aime bien j'ai senti dans les cadeaux
je ne sais pas
si je veux juste en attend des fois je
voudrais faire une voiture mais je
taperai aujourd'hui dans leur forme
je marche beaucoup l'art change pas vous
n'avez jamais été tenté par l'idée vous
louez iott au festival de cannes
si j'étais toi tu es aussi de ça mais ma
femme s en fout complètement mondial on
a une espèce d'inertie puis on sentit ou
est ce que vous vous êtes fait tatouer
cette petite étoile au service militaire
non mais pourquoi parce que j'étais
réformer lit que ce soit nous qui
paieraient motifs pathologique
ça c'est marrant j'ai bien commencé
vraiment l'homme des bois depuis de quel
bois sortiront au sort de la plupart
sont la sologne
excusez-nous parents mon père un taulier
ma mère faisait des enfants
l'hyperémotivité de ses 19 ans lui sert
maintenant dans ses rôles chirurgien
voyous ingénieurs il est toujours
convaincant vous avez raté la sologne
pour faire quoi l'on doit pouvoir
travailler un peu sur les plages fait un
peu de tout plagistes voyager qu'est ce
qui vous avait donné envie de devenir
comédien savait pas très bien j'avais
envie d'un très fort demandés je ne
pouvais pas le dire
alors j'ai commencé par un mentir je
disais que
j'étais acteur et puis à force de le
dire à des gens depuis avec le fasse
puis je les fais ça corresponde
exactement avec ce que je pouvais avec
ma violence il est marié depuis sept ans
avec elizabeth
quand il ne tourne pas il joue avec son
fils et sa petite fille
je crois beaucoup à la famille je crois
en tout cas que dans la famille on peut
retrouver les joies de l'enfance les la
tribu comment est ce que vous arrivez à
avoir une vie de famille et vie
professionnelle extrêmement remplie
jusqu'à présent j'ai essayé mais
maintenant je m'aperçois c'est très
difficile alors j'ai été obligé
d'arrêter pour essayer de faire avec ma
tribu ce que j'ai envie de faire et puis
moi je ne pense pas aux joues soit un
acteur parce que le texte je sais pas ce
que ces jours je le perds la moitié du
temps et je travaille surtout à essayer
d'être disponible à l'écouté du fantasme
du metteur en scène
alors tant que j'ai eu la disponibilité
est là
et la force de le trouver ça allait mais
maintenant ça me donne de plus en plus
de mal et ça pose de plus en plus de
problèmes avec je te vois ma tribu alors
donc il faut mettre un frein
ça veut dire moins tourné moins tourné
puis essayer enfin au lieu d'être le
fantasme la news j'ai envie de diriger
mon fantasme en faisant 3 au fond n'est
que mon histoire faisant un film dans
lequel je jouerai pas forcément en
essayant de travailler avec les gens qui
nous ressemblent qui avec lesquels on
peut s'écouter votre femme était
comédienne au départ elle a fait un peu
à l'affairé fait du mime pour faire sa
thèse parce que ce colloque et puis elle
est restée à l'état travaille avec
étienne decroux puis elle est restée un
peu parce que ça lui plaisait à la
région et puis après montréal ces
sacrifiés parce que moi je vous fais
deux enfants qui étaient difficiles et
elle a préféré en avoir trois parce que
moi j'en étais un lycée et maintenant
que les enfants sont grands et que
comprendre alors on va essayer de
travailler ensemble et dans les
histoires auxquelles vous pensez il y a
une on retrouve pas je suis pas y en
avoir en tout cas il y aura un rôle de
scénariste d'auteur et de créatrices
certainement vous avez déjà travaillé
quelque chose ensemble
on essaye oui bien sûr la travail assez
mais c'est déjà un drôle de travail
aussi